hello guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Veronica six dose Veronica and I today
are gonna check out from the best fails
best fails of October 2015
funny fail compilation let's see if this
is actually funny
we'll be honest with you guys that
happened to me not a trial going on what
is that there's a camel oh oh
you die from that
what are you doing
ow ah I'm so mad
Oh
fathers voice chicken over
you doing much that's cool yeah that's
cool it doesn't look like a fail
I've never seen that my god
that woman looks are pretty weak
although the last one I went to similar
situation Oh
even see that you totally missed that
people
Oh entertaining that's not cool I mean
if somebody obviously got hurt in that
last it's an epic fail that's really
entertaining ever seen car crashes big
car crashes are awesome I love seeing
cars crash people die in car crashes and
people also sometimes live most of the
time they live yeah and sometimes they
end up paralyzed
but most don't most yeah most don't I've
done me check your lives I've done my
statistical research on this topic right
before we filmed this video let's just
stop talking about car crashes okay so
what you want something I can get on
board with fail compilations you know
like a lot of the times that people send
compilations and I'm like they're not
really worth check it out to be honest
these though I feel like they're worth
checking out because I know you don't
like seeing someone get their crotch it
yeah I personally think it's one of the
funniest things getting your crotch it
[ __ ] hilarious if that hurts me how
does it not hurt you oh no I feel it and
that's what's funny cuz I'm watching
someone else go through it it's really
messed up you really need to work on
your empathy skills this has nothing to
do with a lack of empathy this has
everything to do with the fact that you
have a lack of sense of humor cuz that's
funny that's some funny [ __ ] well if I
punched you in the face right now that's
not funny this is not why I would think
that watch me Larry's balls that could
be fun okay well then you
don't have the same sense of humor as I
do then that's true you guys want to see
me punch him in the face
no the balls I might like that I might
like that
no all right now do it
Oh anyway guys thanks for tuning to the
channel if you're new you can click this
button up here to subscribe it's up
there and become a rejected core sure
you can check out Veronica's Channel
acoustic covers originals and I recently
put together a sketch called in between
takes with Ryan and brandy and Veronica
and brandy co-star in this picture
Veronica is getting the most comments
when it comes to this video you guys got
to check it out I've never put so much
work into something in my entire life
and there's still a lot more work to be
done
joke Ave Mela hey guys I've been been
watching binge watching all your videos
and they have been making me laugh so
much please have a shout-out and elicit
be crazy for reading this thanks for the
follow on Instagram all right here's
what we're gonna do for you cuz we're
gonna do for you Joe
just to make Joe happy calling Melissa
maybe if I call national answer Alyssa
this is Ryan right I'm in the middle of
doing a shout out a man named Joe KBM
Ella wanted to say thanks for falling
him on Instagram but you didn't pick up
your goddamn phone you're supposed to
pick up your [ __ ] phone whenever I
[ __ ] call you don't ever do this
again or I'll cut you do you understand
if you want to add British I'm pretty
sure you scared the kids outside and
I'll murder your [ __ ] children if you
ever have any thanks Joe give me a
chance to get that out